hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play outlast
okay we might be getting close to the
very end of the game so we have no time
to waste here alright can I go this is
open sorry I didn't even see that that
was open okay so we're in an underground
corridor filled with dead bodies that
have died in a rather fantastic fashion
it's okay camera I know you're scared
but we must persevere we must carry on
to where we need to go lest we be lost
forever morphogenetic indeed wait I'm
going the wrong way it's that way okay
wait whatever all right so we're going
down into these labs where I'm a su oh
my this guy seems to have lost his
insides all over the floor here and some
over the walls and some on the counter
yeah I mean seriously how did these guys
died did they just explode I mean I'm
assuming the walrider
did all this and I'm assuming that the
walrider went inside them in like a big
water balloon with blood and guts and oh
man this is just grody grody okay anyway
moving forward and oh this looks like a
long haul that something can chase me
down mmm I wonder what's gonna happen is
that outside Oh looks so lovely now oh
it stops raining and the Sun came out go
camera I know you're excited but come on
now okay we haven't watch a lab spoiled
one of those spoiled samples of
something and oh oh is that the
morphogenetic engine really that that's
it oh hang on
this is a morphogenetic engine a few
lines of mathematics and algorithm
reprogram us turn us into nightmare
factories a few numbers on a dry erase
board
give me a hacks on a few hours alone
with dr. Wernicke's corpse I feel I owe
him a debt no vengeance is not the way
just because you lost two fingers and
probably most of your sanity it doesn't
mean that you deserve to have vengeance
oh just this guy's top half one
they're just big giant splatters of
blood a Rorschach test of blood
everywhere
I mean this underground facility kind of
means that there's a lot more people
that could work down here this is why
there was that thing that was gonna
chase me down the hallway oh it all
makes sense now
Wow ain't gonna get me I'm pretty I'm
pretty much a parkour expert little
piggie now now little piggy go home
little piggy gonna go run free little
piggy go home little piggy go now little
piggy no no hey I'm just talking about
you
Oh laughs poor guy
whoa whoa whoa oh my god oh my god oh
this is the way you died rip to pieces
from the inside watching your marrow
scatter on a concrete wall you've
escaped one hell Chris Walker god help
me but I somehow hope you didn't find
another wait was that Chris Walker was
that the guy's name was that is that my
name I thought my name was Rupert
Morphin nine more food choking anyway
all right so I guess I go wait no
there's a note here I missed it
yeah let me get this I didn't check
these rooms thoroughly see my fourteenth
op Tosti of a walrider patient showing
no more signs of accepting the therapy
than any of the others there have been
slate games and cell migration and
morphogenesis including effects similar
to human growth hormone but nothing to
suggest the stable creation of a
sentient independent swarm what so tired
doubting my judgment will submit another
request relieve the psychological cost
of using such far gone and per further
provoked patients is more than I feel I
can handle may suggest hanging less hope
on the far-flung theories of a senile
Nazi and move towards using a simpler
mechanical engine based on major sperm
protein we'll definitely suggest harsher
chemical restraints Murkoff security
killed page 91 after he overcame the
enough tranquilizers to put down a
hockey team I'm afraid the hormone
therapy is interacting with our chemical
restricts and a counterproductive manner
hi who are you that guy birkoff
to be dead yeah no such good yeah you
look good I'm alive okay
if you say so yeah that might have been
a problem use insane Oh crazy okay okay
whatever you say man moving today man
maybe shouldn't be talking about this
hidden in such loud tones I gotta kill
Billy I gotta cover references okay oh
that was why the arrow is pointing over
this way because these way because the
morphogenetic engine is actually over
here hello oh the bathroom where
everyone went to die what a big surprise
okay someone oh there isn't even oh
these are showers okay well that's
somehow a little more morbid alright I
guess I don't need batteries anymore
I've been feeling I'm getting close to
the end I mean he's gonna make me try to
kill Billy but I don't know how I'm
gonna succeed where so many before me
have failed I don't even know why Billy
is leaving me alive I mean Billy could
have killed me at any moment I'm like a
I'm like a lost child in a place I don't
belong I mean he doesn't kill a lot of
the insane patients so maybe he thinks
that I'm way too insane to be killed
yeah strange okay I don't see anything
here so I'm assuming that this is what
does that no that's just it
tray table there's a lot of doors to
open but I don't see a lot of stuff okay
there's some sort of alarm blaring and I
don't see anything here okay down this
way there's a hole oh you heard what we
were talking about me killing you don't
worry about that Wow Billy oh you're
such a trickster ah ooh we joke around
all the time Billy Bob we have a good
time we have a good time oh you got me
oh no I thought it was gonna be a
one-hit kill thing oh oh oh squeeze her
a little piggy no no oh oh no oh
just how much books to get away from him
he's awfully quick and he can kind of go
through walls it's gonna make it a
little difficult all right so I gotta
figure out a way I don't think I can
hide from this a whole these other guys
didn't weren't very successful hey man
let me look scout out uh no definitely
don't go in here because I would die
well maybe I could loop around there
that might be a good place okay let's
see come on bring it on Billy no
actually I'm gonna no no don't do it I'm
your friend Billy let me friend
close the door haha one door good job
there okay
oh wait no I got some distance on him
okay maybe I'll be able to do this come
on open all right hurry hurry come on I
guess I don't gotta do the little piggy
chin anymore because they'll pick a guy
ain't here no more
little piggy no no little Pete you're
home yeah I seem to have gotten a lot of
space on him oh the dark I don't know if
cloak closing doors will help against
him but ah oh
nobody can then become a new dummy a new
diver I saw him through here
okay no through here I saw I mean was
just standing there maybe he gave up
maybe he knew that was way too Pro to be
dotted by him see do not worship the
swarm nor allow the delusions of the
patients to influence your beliefs any
sentient being based in this technology
will go so it will be so far superior to
us that the illusion of godliness will
be reasonable we have always looked into
chaos and called it God we are now
blessed with sufficient power that such
believe could destroy us do not be
tempted remember that you are scientists
dead scientists but scientists
nonetheless close that behind me
birthday alright let's go bring it on
really bring is a world
how about we record this for
journalistic integrity Wow
alright then seems to be some sort of
stableness oh yeah the assembler the
feed chambers the precursor molecules
vague memories of nanotechnology
articles I've read online probably drunk
probably distracted not nearly enough to
know how to destroy it but Billy is in
the center of it
find him kill him and this well at least
I'm going beyond my journalistic roots
and venturing into a world of murder
turn off the valve for the life support
whoa it's actually you Billy are you
doing Billy you don't look so good Wow
alright then from Billy's patient
reports he ought to be 23 years old he
looks like at least 50 years of rough
road bein scratched deep into what I can
see killing you would be an act of
kindness if you say so I think he looks
pretty good I think he's looking pretty
good they're not so bad that's a weird
at all he's got some color in his cheeks
probably from all the blood that he's
spread it around well you know coloring
under this okay can I go in here nope
okay that's a jiggly jiggly lock door I
need to go down and find a FAL why can't
I just smash the ball but oh what what
what hi there do you have something to
say to me okay no all right then fine
why is this one filled with blood
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna keep asking
any questions because I know I'm not
gonna get any answers you stop doing
that what the hell are these what the
hell is going on here
I don't even think I want to know one
notes more notes this is Billy's hope
Billy hopes lungs his liver its
life-support machine the size of a
football stateman to keep one lunatic
alive poop it all break it all he has to
die if you say so but I am assuming that
Billy is gonna come out of the walls
soon and try to stop me because that's
what he's been want to do before see is
there like a big red button that I could
press big red button oh no there's
things here uh learn from me if not by
my precepts at least by my example how
dangerous is the acquirement of
knowledge and how much happier that
modest man than he who aspires to become
greater than his nature allows quote
from Frankenstein ha ha Oh
it all ends with me turning a valve if
you say so
do not turn the valve Oh what's gonna do
bad now I turn that valve yeah
is there a filly coming after me dr.
Billy coming after me oh I'm not even
look I didn't even see it but I don't
yeah I know he's after me I know he's a
common I know he's a venture and closer
to close the door
goodbye thanks for coming Billy I don't
know if we can actually go through walls
or if he can actually what is that oh I
thought that was a thingy I just saw the
blood there okay so now what
aha I see something up there it's
blaring lights just assuming that's
where I'm supposed to go I'll put Donald
yup potato ha little piggy no no little
piggy go home oh baby oh baby oh baby oh
baby oh no not that one you stupid git
okay whatever don't matter maybe I need
to record stuff while I'm running
probably probably not I'm getting the
poop out of here
yeah yeah yeah yeah maybe I don't know I
don't know what's going on just climb in
a bunch of stairs ah yeah made it
nailed it at least I knew to jump that
one find out how is that even fair you
don't do that you son of a [ __ ] okay
the last chase come on bring it on
we're not bring it on yeah okay go go go
go come on come on baby come on baby
how many stairs do I have to climb here
such an e okay okay okay what do we do
aha yep good enough there we go
wait disable his white
okay Billy doesn't seem too happy about
that but what do I do
what did that say disable his life his
failsafe life what do I gotta go all the
way back down now I didn't see any other
way so I'm assuming yes oh oh
that's dark okay all right what do I do
now I don't know what that meant I
didn't see any other way to go somebody
too happy about that
Oh No
I'm still running how could I still be
running after that maybe use this
helping me out by give me a quick way
down thanks Billy thanks Billy
okay all right which way do I go now cuz
we do it go I don't know
where'd it go I don't see any lights
blaring tell me where to go is he coming
after me oh come on
right here oh god damn it right there
right there okay let's just assume that
I got that on the first drive whoa hey
none of that no no oh crap hey hey Billy
[Music]
[Applause]
what I'm alive how am I live I'm not
doing too good yeah suck on that Billy
that's what you get but I have a feeling
that that monster went inside me oh my
leg is not doing good oh yeah whatever
that thing was I think as it as Billy
was dying it went inside me
[Music]
okay am i okay no I'm not okay I'm not
gonna be okay definitely not gonna be
okay
I mean if Billy needed life support to
keep that thing going I don't think that
my body is gonna be able to handle it as
ready as my body is don't think it's
gonna handle it
well dr. Morgan heimer wernicki Billy's
home Billy's here to say hi to you man
this reporters sure has taken a beating
but so far he's not exploded and his
intestines aren't all over the basement
Oh things are going dark for marshall
mathers here Oh
becomes a horse is that why you shot me
[Applause]
[Music]
hahaha the end alright man that was
crazy um if you didn't get what happened
there well you probably got what
happened anonymous say it anyway what
happened was the thing went inside me
just to like barely survived you know
like sort of use my body as a life
support when they killed me it escaped
and then started killing everyone there
so I don't know the science behind it
but then again I don't know the side
find anything in there that was a great
game
fantastic I'm gonna barely be called an
indie horror at this point that was
pretty much a triple a horror title
absolutely phenomenal I mean some people
are talking to they didn't spoil the
ending for me but they said they were
kind of disappointed with the ending I
kind of liked it I like the way that
ended I mean I'm okay with the reporter
not making it out of it alive and I'm
okay with leaving this open conclusion
where we didn't stop the evil it was
just really really really well done
graphics were amazing the gameplay I was
scared throughout the whole thing it got
kind of repetitive for a little bit
there and you know the the the patience
didn't become as much of a threat before
but when that big guy came out each time
you know he was still kind of a shock to
see him and sad to see him died not
really happy to see him getting dragged
through a great leg that it was brutal
it was bloody who's gory I don't know
where the excessive sexuality came in
beyond the beginning of the game who's
like Lorna you expect to protect you I
thought in the female war there might
have been something there but no I
didn't even see a female patient I mean
there was the two naked guys in doubt
that was about it anyway
that was absolutely fantastic um if I
had one criticism about it it would be
that you know this whole story is based
around insanity like losing your mind
the patients are going insane the
science experiments is about driving
people insane so that they can use their
psychosomatic abilities to make this
thing appear and the main villain is
just absolutely crazy bonkers like a
little kid that's like would wait to
mature our power you know but
it was always alluded to that the main
character was going slowly insane as he
went through this game and yet that was
never taken advantage of you know every
time I thought I saw something out of
the corner of my eye it was really there
every time I thought I saw something
that was kind of insane it was actually
there you know and there was a great
thing where the camera could have had so
many like camera tricks he planned he
takes off the Kari Whitman oh you know
it was never really done him and there
was a little bit of a flickering with
the camera towards the end there but we
never really got to feel like the like
you know the main character was turning
into a patient at the facility I mean
there was constantly the patients were
like how do you know you're not a
patient and there could have been this
huge mindfuck with the players he's like
Oh am I really here am I really there or
am i a part of this or what's going on
but um it always seemed to me like the
main character was sane the whole time
like perfectly sane totally with it
totally had a grasp on everything they
need to do but either other than that
you know that little bit that's just
little something I'm I talked a lot of
it's a little thing in comparison to the
whole game it was a phenomenal game I
recommend to everyone played I mean if
you watch it yourself and you don't want
played I understand perfectly you're at
the end of the video I mean you've seen
the whole game by now so anyway
sincerely that was amazing
I hope red barrels does more in the
future outlast is incredible incredible
game and a machine for pigs is coming up
next so get ready for that so thank you
all so much for watching click the
annotation know more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you
place I hope you guys all enjoy it for
yourself please support the developer he
is work obviously works with a lot of
people in
I'm probably the best sign of an expiry
you're gonna find
[Music]
it is his baby so he wants it to be best
oh boy I get to go into an abandoned
house in the middle of the night
this is gonna be phenom